[Music]
I'm Fraser McDonald I'm a product guy at
Google working on cloud IOT so IOT core
as a product and a lot of the extended
IOT ecosystem that Google's I got a lot
of offerings and and really excited to
have you here today for a pretty
specific topic and it's one that when we
were putting this talk together we were
really excited to do because with the
smaller islands you get a chance to chat
about something that's actionable so we
want to talk today about some real
specifics of Reap lat forming because
it's a terrifying thing to a lot of
companies but it's a huge mover for a
lot of companies as well so just to get
us kicked off as a bit of an idea of
who's sitting in the audience how many
people here have actually gone through
it some form of Technology reap lat
forming themselves in the past sure yeah
I go to Mount on the group that's
probably felt the the pains and
struggles and the benefit on the other
side what about been part of a company
that's discussed a reap lot forming but
decided against it a little bit yeah I
had those conversations come up too so
we wanted to make sure to cover some of
the specifics today and we're excited to
do it so I want to start by asking you
this how many of these buzzwords and
Technology trends over the years either
strike fear in your heart because you
were part of the team responsible for
what are we gonna do about this or are
you know fond memory of something we've
gone through personally y2k is the one
that stands out for me I grew up in a
house with the dad who is a disaster
recovery planner professionally for a
bank and so y2k rolled around it was his
job to make sure that the Canadian
Imperial Bank of Commerce didn't go
under because of y2k can't tell the
Canadian accent that's where it's from
so we had a bunker in our basement full
of canned foods so I still have
associations of fears of what's gonna go
on with y2k but each one of these is a
technology of trend that's happened over
the last 15 20 years and each one of
these is also a real opportunity when
the rise of mobile started coming in
earnest
companies realized they needed to adopt
new strategy so that their businesses
were capable of handling mobile when
ecommerce started springing up companies
realized we need to
some pretty significant technical
overhaul so that we can make sure we can
sell all of our product online and we're
kind of getting to that point in the IOT
now as well as the IOT is getting more
mature and more both consumer and
industrial products are launching that
are connected to the Internet either
just as sensor networks or sensors and
actuators that you're talking back to
these technologies are starting to get
codified we're starting to get a few
more protocols emerging we're starting
to get a common understanding of what
are the building blocks of device
management of handling the data and how
do we tie users into the ecosystem and
as this is happening it's following the
same trends as a lot of these did
companies are realizing ok I started
with a POC and we put something together
internally that worked and we built or
we had a nice I shop that built for us
but we want to take it production grade
so at Google we're having a lot of
conversations about Reap lat for me and
I think there's a big reason for it and
that's we're hitting the point where
companies are not all greenfield anymore
there are a lot of companies out there
today that have some form of connected
product in the market it's got a bit of
internet connectivity and they're
looking at going to the next generation
of the product they stuck when I there
it was a pilot project they got success
with it and they're almost victims of
their own success realizing we need to
scale things out we need to be able to
roll out a new feature that we didn't
anticipate and so a lot of the
conversations that we're having at
Google are with companies who have
something stood up already I need to
figure out how to integrate it it's a
common conversation so we're seeing
roughly two camps of companies that are
going through reap platforms and one is
motivated by the pushes it's we built
something that was meant for a couple
thousand users and we'd like to be able
to handle a couple hundred thousand or
one of the major pieces of technology
that we are reliant on is going in a
business and we need to make
accommodations for this yesterday a lot
of it also is things are getting out of
hand because we didn't build this to
scale and we're running our own
infrastructure we can't keep the costs
up another big push factor is I'm not
sure that our technical team in-house is
the one that should be focusing entirely
on our IOT product we need them for
other things
just as often there's something on the
other side there's the PO factors and
that's what we were talking about new
technologies are emerging new standards
are emerging IOT core as a product that
Dively
and they's I've ly acquisition from
January and the IOT core product in
Google are coming together to provide is
device management as a service its
connectivity its device security its
communication over known product
protocols a lot of these technologies in
the IOT are starting to become standards
and companies want to take advantage of
that I don't want to run my own message
broker I don't want to run my own
relationship between users and devices
similarly they want to take advantage of
the teams that are building at other
companies so their own team doesn't have
to if you can piggyback off of
somebody's real-time database technology
or you can handle stream processing or
analytics through a
software-as-a-service tool it means that
your team of 2 3 10 engineers in-house
can focus on something that's just
specific to your business so there are a
lot of reasons why this conversation is
coming up at companies but just as often
there are a lot of reasons why it's
terrifying and the conversations are
slow I had a conversation with somebody
recently who the quote from him was you
know replac forming is not a great way
to get promoted but it's an excellent
way to get fired and I think I think
it's a common sentiment because there's
a lot of fear around the idea of taking
a plane that's flying in the air and
swapping out the engine taking a product
that's already launched in your
customers hands and you know that you
can get better out of it but you're
really afraid of touching something
that's already out there in the field
and they're real risks you don't want to
be the company that's on the front of
the newspaper because your product shut
off somebody pushed a firmware image
that they shouldn't have had permission
to push and they bricked ten thousand
devices or you don't be the company
that's wasting time and gets the call
from your exact that says why is my
engineering team working on building a
new device connectivity layer don't we
already have that and you don't have a
good answer what's the ROI of why we're
switching over to something so we wanted
to take some time when we were putting
together the talk today to address these
points head-on they're real practical
considerations
and they don't often get talked about
directly so we're hoping to do that in a
bit of a unique format what we're gonna
do is talk through some of the best
practices that Rick from Augusta who's
gonna come up and join me in a minute as
an SI and myself working on the platform
side of IOT have seen emerged when
companies are going through what are the
best practices what are some of the
things you should take away and Rick's
gonna walk us through a couple of
examples of companies that have actually
been there and done that and how they
made it happen because tackling these
problems should not be enormous and
while they should weigh all of these
risks these risks should not stop you
from getting the benefits so I'm going
to invite Rick up and let's take a look
at a couple of these best practices so
the first one we're going to talk about
is run a tracer bullet and for those who
aren't familiar with the expression a
tracer bullets meant to indicate what's
something that we can do and end what's
something that we can carve out as a
small piece of our working solution and
go through the process from start to
finish with maybe a subset of our
customers or maybe one site only because
you're gonna run into problems you're
gonna need to answer the call at 2:00
a.m. because something's broken you're
gonna realize that you forgot that your
users had to log in through a new system
instead of an old system you're gonna
realize that oh yeah that particular
device isn't capable of holding a
firmware image that big something's
gonna go wrong and so one of the best
practices you can take away is pick a
site in an industrial context maybe it's
one site that was an early customer and
who will be very forgiving and really
eager to try out some of the new
technology you're rolling out or if it's
a consumer context pick a subset of your
users that might be power users and
might be a bit more forgiving and walk
through the whole process with them and
to give a bit of an idea in real terms
of what we've seen this is what we
recommend for how you stage things out
you want to spend a good amount of time
on that tracer bullet three to six
months should go into after you've had
the conversation and you've justified
why are we making this change how much
time should you be looking at putting
towards this spend up to six months with
that early customer to make sure that
the people on your support team know
what they're doing the people on the
technical side know exactly what they're
doing you've actually gone through the
process
suppressing the button and feeling the
fear because that's gonna make each of
these stages down the road work a lot
more smoothly running in parallel is
just a great idea in any reap lat
forming and running rolling out any new
technology it's sometimes thought of as
you know blue green that you have a live
deployment and you're swapping in
getting something up and running before
you're swapping into your whole fleet
and finally the crossover stage is
pretty quick
once you've walked through all this so
I'm going to turn it over to Rick to
talk a bit about a case where he's seen
exactly this Thank You Frasier and
thanks everybody for having me up I'm
Rick Erickson I'm actually the chief
cloud strategist at augusto and I also
run very specifically our IOT practice
area and so I've had the pleasure of
working with a number of really
interesting companies at different
stages of reap lat form and one of them
that I want to tell you about really
quickly is a company called limelight
this is a very innovative company they
they launched a product actually about
nine years ago and the industrial
lighting in control space they had
originally a vision for taking ZigBee
mesh and finding use cases they could
implement that mesh in and ended up
partnering with some very large lighting
control components and working with some
of the some of the providers that
actually delivered these these lights at
both the industrial scale parking and
some other locations and found wild
success and very interesting company and
that you know as you describe the use
cases of companies that sort of tested
an idea and realized some significant
some some level of success initially but
then we're sort of as a result of their
success ended up having you know
challenges down the road because they
didn't scale appropriately or we're
stuck with an architecture that was
dated and needed to be modernized
limelight certainly fills that so with
limelight you know one of the things
that that they had a challenge with was
we want to modernize our entire stack
but we kind of don't know where to start
and so we also haven't partnered with
anybody outside of our engineering team
in the past so how do we do that in a
way that allows us to sort of test that
concern but also saw a problem
inside our stack of services that were
the most impactful and so in line like
skates they happen to have an MVNO that
it acquired technology this is a
technology that have been quired by
three or four other companies and this
this acquisition of technology was
really no more than a connection broker
this is sort of you know in in the world
prior to platforms and this company had
a proprietary connection broker that was
right in the middle of their stack and
and they they had a lot of concerns
about this stack going end-of-life and
being stuck with what do we do if these
guys go out of business we have hundreds
of customers huge customers like like
you know the parking garage here at
Moscone and others that use our
technology and these organizations would
literally have concerns about
configurations going offline and being
able to manage them if they if they were
end-of-life and so for them a big part
of their their vision around this is you
know how do we how do we validate that
this this important plumbing in between
our devices and our back-office is going
to function as appropriate and as
expected so so let me tell you kind of
how we did it so I'm not going to get
too deep into into the architecture but
I want to give you kind of some sense of
where they were at so I mentioned their
initial state I just mentioned that are
using this third-party em you know they
have a proprietary gateway that speaking
basically a proprietary protocol and
that and that server in the middle is
where the MVNO is hosting this this
broker and on the edge of the
application services that could read and
interpret that data coming from these
these ZigBee devices on the on the end
and so what we what we wanted to do is
literally kind of think about this as a
canary in the coalmine their use cases
are they have a multi-tenant system
that's deployed they also have customers
that have regulatory restrictions that
require them to deploy their their
entire technology stack in an isolated
premise cloud right so they have two two
concerns that they have to kind of
validate for and so what we did was is
we actually set up a common iso
certified broker that would run on cloud
platform but also be containerized and
capable of operating and a high
Ritt scenario as well or on the Prem so
again fairly simple problem but but in
order to make sure that we had literally
a tracer bullet running from edge to
edge of this system we wanted to
validate that there weren't going to be
problems in both scenarios and they
certainly wanted to determine that they
had the right partner to help them in
this journey so so the end result was we
were able to to basically horseshoe in
this broker service rewrite the mqtt
client on the edge for the Gateway and
and then so we were supporting the same
hardware that was already living at the
edge no changes to that to that hardware
at all and then support a client broker
that could also interpret the messaging
coming back and so this was a service on
the edge that was a service on the edge
this was a service in the back end and
and then we implemented basically kind
of a bridge that allowed us to kind of
put a canary in the coalmine right and
validate that from the edge to edge we
were able to reduce that risk it would
function as expected and so our first
deployments for them and this is one of
the sort of the learnings from this is
deploy at at an isolated environment
that doesn't affect all of your tenants
at once right have that be your starting
point so good learning there and then
you know pick something that is going to
be you know relatively impactful but but
not necessarily impact all your
customers at once and so we took that
initial tracer bullet ran it through
validated it and then move to the multi
tenant deployment after that so that was
our that was our that was our first set
of learning great thanks Rick and I
should say as we're going through these
customer use cases too we're gonna have
an opportunity after we go through four
examples with you to chat with the
companies we're gonna have a QA and
invite people and invite the companies
up to speak about their experiences so
if you get a question as you're going
through that we don't cover make sure to
jot it down remember there's gonna be a
mic at the end so the second one is
understand your change tolerance and
this is an important one especially as
you're communicating a replate forming
story through your own
there's a lot of fear of how big this
can get and it's a reasonable fear and
what we've noticed in a couple of rounds
of Reap lat forming with many companies
is that there are roughly three patterns
you can go all the way from like medium
through to heavy and you need to know as
a company going into this how strategic
is this to us and how much risk
tolerance do we have how much change
tolerance do we have and what's the
timeline going to look like so a Reap
lat forum does not have to be an
enormous take over all at once the light
option here is perhaps replacing a
single component or supplementing a
single component this could be taking an
architecture that's already using one
flavor of MQTT for device communication
and moving to a different MQTT device
broker not much of an interruption and
you can do it piecemeal it's a much
easier sell if you're doing it in parts
the mid-size ones are where you're
adding a couple of different new pieces
to the mix you might need to take in a
new data format or you might be working
on live databases and this is where it
can get tricky because you're gonna have
to be doing some hot swapping the
heaviest of the read the read platforms
are foolery architectures and it's
almost never recommended in fact if
you're thinking about a reap lap forming
problem I guarantee you can break it
down into smaller bite-sized pieces and
we'll talk a bit in a bit as well that
it's probably pretty easy if you sit
down with you and your executive team
and the business people in your
organization to identify what's the one
things is gonna have the most impact
you're gonna know so each of the sizes
of these reap lap farming's is something
that you have to know as a company so
Rick I'm hoping you can walk us through
an example of exactly this style of
decision-making yeah you bet so let me
tell you a story about actually we're
lucky enough to have one of the one of
the innovators of this platform that was
developed by group a do here and you'll
talk to him when we do our QA but group
group ATO is a is a municipal busting
both short heart long-haul and delivery
busting one of the largest in in Latin
America and Spain and they have a really
innovation a number of innovation
programs that are built out for their
consumers and ways to sort of track
driver behavior a series of services
that are called SCI AB that are actually
quite sophisticated and were built
almost 15 years ago now to support those
user needs and these are outfitted
across the bulk of their fleet and you
know one one of the challenges that that
they had was opportunities to to add
innovative services across these these
existing services but also how do they
figure out how to take this sort of
legacy stack of services and implement
them in a more modernized way and again
sophisticated complicated buses moving
set of services so let me know this is
our reap lat forming patterns that's
what we just covered that did we not I'm
going the wrong way sorry okay so so you
know what what a do really wanted to do
is they've got an innovator that that
was thinking about what are there
opportunities for me to take my existing
stack of services and implement more
innovative problems using machine
learning and analytics and I want to
start with how can I figure out both the
impact of that and understand what's
what's capable and at the same time I've
got this legacy stack of service of
services that are being used to deliver
to live with my existing product to
market I can't blow that up because
that's got to still operate and and I
also need to take you know consider
where the where the places throughout my
stack of services my hardware stack that
is going to impact the organization the
most so at the edge they've got a
relatively expensive computing device
that effectively will will will handle
all the communication between the bus
driver the systems inside providing
services to consumers that that can pay
you know using using paid service
a mobile device but also provide our
entertainment services on the bus and
other other behavioral analytics and
that that piece of device is a
proprietary embedded Windows device
that's very expensive for them to not
only source but also to to maintain and
provide sort of longer-term so so that
the the the use case that I described is
not uncommon we find a lot of companies
that have sort of older and and aged
infrastructure at the edge they need to
figure out ways of how can they replace
that with a lower-cost
device that can be more readily sourced
but also still provide the same level of
compute and intelligence that they need
to to support their existing set of
services right I'm sure that all of you
maybe have had experiences with with
using really data technology and seeing
how it works and this is the same
concern that Ayoo had so we we decided
that we would help them on this journey
by helping them stand up a feasibility
proof of concept that would that would
validate that they could still they
could support this larger vision for
advanced services and and be able to
also begin to start materializing a
model for an edge computing device that
would be much less expensive to source
the bill materials for and also provide
a higher level of performance to support
kind of the vision that that in this
case Vern a and his team had to validate
that this was even possible so so just
to give you some sense of kind of what
we use we've got a Raspberry Pi here
running running Android things a very
lightweight device this this device
actually sat on a number of pilot buses
and and we use this device at the edge
to effectively replace this ruggedized
Windows PC so that device was able to to
take engine diagnostic data off the cam
bus which is where we basically have it
have a vehicle controller that uses a
proprietary protocol and then pulls that
data into this can card device and and
ultimately pushes this to our
to our Android things Raspberry Pi so
you know anything about things you know
that it's a powerful piece of hardware
that can that can also support depending
on what you know implementation of PI
you put but can also support doing some
processing at the edge and so our our
validation here was proving that we
could pull data into IOT core
implementing that through a data
engineering environment and improving
that we could classify data to
eventually be part of developing a
machine learning model to support
vehicle prognostics or diagnostic data
and so so we we completed that project
in a very short period of time about
four weeks and we were able to to settle
nerves and concerns that number one a
device at the edge which is much less
expensive could even support a similar
type of model that was in the
visionaries head for this but also that
we could support the same level of
service quality and improve value in in
in an innovative service like
prognostics and in machine learning type
services to to ultimately improve the
value of the product to the market and
just to give you some idea of the of the
sophistication of this vision I do
actually built out a comprehensive kind
of layout here of what the architecture
could look like in the future and you
know this is this is the this is ideally
what I want you to focus on here is that
you know what we're trying to do when
you when you try to validate a system
like this is really understand what's
the most impactful business solution
that you want to put in front of your
users and or back to the business and
and how can you surface that and the
simplest way write a three to four week
project you're not going to solve the
entire problem but you'll get a very
good sense of the impact of how you
could deploy this and I can implement
this to support a much more
comprehensive business case and and and
then take that learning to how it fits
into your overall roadmap strategy so we
were able to prove both of these points
on the machine learning side to support
future syad features and also how to use
and analytics services to support larger
business intelligence and eventually
service that to the customer and to the
back to the business alright you get
that one thanks Rick
ok so best practice number three
partition your problem and this is one
that we've talked a bit about already
this is a pretty simple concept that can
save you a ton of time as you're working
through what do we really want to reap
lat form when you take a look at an IOT
solution it's possible to break it down
into pieces and generally those pieces
follow some consistent buckets
you've got your devices in your device
communication you've got your users and
their applications and their permissions
you've got your third-party integrations
and then you've got your data Lake in
your analytics going on in the cloud and
when you take a look at an architecture
like this the pieces start to tease
apart and so if you're sitting down with
your team and thinking we're not able to
scale fast enough or it requires a
manual provisioning every time we
install on site or we need to launch a
new feature but we don't have an
integration with a partner or we're not
really happy with the way that our apps
are set up right now chances are you're
talking about one specific piece of this
technical architecture you don't need to
rip and replace absolutely everything
you can be pretty tactical about how you
do it so if you take a look at this
diagram here this is an example
architecture for how an IOT product
might be set up on GCP using GCP tools
on the left hand side you have IOT core
which is our product for connecting to
devices and there are a lot of fantastic
products inside of GCP for data
ingestion what's unique about IOT core
is that it's purpose-built for
bi-directional communication and with
devices at the edge so it does two
things it does messaging back and forth
with these devices and it provides them
a secure identity that they can use
inside the rest of the GCP ecosystem
then the rest of the products of storage
compute analytics are ones that you
might be familiar with from GCP on the
right-hand side are the ones that you
might be using for your users you might
be building something on App Engine or
you might as will hear about be building
something using firebase
so to illustrate this story a little bit
better I'd like to invite Dallas on and
Dallas is with a company called Outlet
who's gone through exactly this kind of
consideration quite recently
thanks a lot Dallas all right
apparently down not up all right so I am
from outlet as you can see here we're a
health technology company founded in
2013 the amazing thing about outlet is
that we actually can provide useful
information to parents at the right time
and what we anticipate being able to do
is to change the way people or parents
worry about their about their babies by
being able to tell them if their baby is
ok in 2013 our founders had a problem
that they wanted to solve and that was
to know if their babies coming home from
the hospital that were in the NICU were
ok and that they've been monitored for
months at the NICU but when they came
home they didn't have anything to tell
them if they were ok all the sudden they
were they were on many monitors and then
overnight and they didn't have a monitor
at all and so parents are worried now
that's one use case and then there's a
use case where everybody knows who has
kids is my baby still breathing and
going into the room creeping in and kind
of seeing if the baby's breathing and
not getting enough sleep and so this our
product is able to provide that data to
customers and to these parents so they
get the rest they need and it's in the
it's an amazing thing that we can
provide for our customers right now last
night there are over 75,000 babies being
monitored by our monitor and if you do
the math that's about five billion
heartbeats in a given night that we are
counting and we are collecting all of
that data we are collecting that data
and putting it into bigquery to run
analysis on different types of profiles
of babies that we
find and what we had to do back in 2013
was focus on our product we as a company
don't want to worry about the
connectivity engine behind it and so we
really want to focus on our product and
what we can provide to there to our
customers and so I kind of want to
elaborate a little bit more on how we
you partition our problems and before
deciding on a replac forming and give
you a scenario here with our company in
history where we first provided our
product it was a simple monitor on the
baby's foot to the to a mobile device
and if anyone knows hardware that's a
Bluetooth module on the foot two to your
mobile device who you just think about
it and how much range you're gonna get
if your signals did tuned by a fleshy
foot well we realized not as quickly as
we should've that we needed to have a
gateway and so when we decided that we
needed to have a gateway we decided to
go with a technology partner to help
connect our device to the cloud and so
with that we were able to kind of leave
the connectivity to our partners and
then focus on our core product but as we
continue to grow we we really want to be
able to focus on the next problem we
have we want to be able to scale we
really want a monitor to go home with
every baby that's going home from the
hospital and in the u.s. that's four
million babies babies a year and so as
we want to scale we need to look at
being able to provide a product that can
actually go to every baby and the
problem we have right now is that as we
focus on our product itself
who's focusing on the connectivity and
who's focusing on that ability to scale
and to to talk to every parent and talk
to every every monitor and so we really
want to now look at our problem as how
do we solve our
connectivity problem with our platform
it's as our architecture is a simple
architecture that is I would say like
just any other connected device where
you have your device management and your
authentication and you want to pass data
to and from from your device in our
mobile in our mobile application which I
just kind of show you here
we actually provide that data and then
from that mobile application you can
control the device and so our goal in
Reap lat forming is being able to modify
our product of on our needs and our
schedule and so when we look at our
problem we say what isn't working for us
now instead of trying to take the whole
go to the heavy side of things with your
timeline and try to really check it all
at once we take one aspect of our
product and move it over that makes it
better for us so that we can actually
meet our mission of providing
information to parents at the right time
and so our first first thought there is
how can we be more agile and how can we
actually rely on third parties as
partners in our product not just throw
it over the fence here I need a
connectivity throw it back and it's just
a generic solution but how can we
utilize our partners as usual eyes third
parties as our partners where they
support our mission as well and that
they can actually move at our own pace
and so what we want to do is take the
problem and chunk by chunk and our first
pass was to take our user database and
bring that under our control where we
can actually have better features that
support our customers with with an
out-of-the-box option it gets us to
market quicker but it doesn't
necessarily meet our negative meet our
the needs of our users in the long term
and so we take one aspect over and right
now we're in the process of migrating
our users to a to a user database that's
run out of firebase and it was built by
in Google and so as we take that on we
can control it and we can modify it to
our needs
as opposed to relying on a third party
that is is out of the box and so looking
to the future is being able to own our
own destiny and develop a product that
meets our needs as well as the needs of
our customers and so by partitioning it
and focusing on one aspect at a time
you'll be able to make modifications and
improve your features without causing
angst on your on your customers because
I can tell you this the worst thing
about not having control of your own
platform is is a real scenario with with
75,000 moms with babies who have little
sleep and all they want to know is that
their babies okay and instead of going
into the room they want to open the app
from the comfort of their bed and then
they get a message saying oh the device
can't be reached not being able to
control that time is is the worst worse
for us as a company and it's terrible
for our customers and so we want to be
able to control our our platform and
control the uptime and control the SLA s
and the features that are there because
what happens when someone pushes an
update on the on a generic system at
9:00 p.m. at night and that's when all
of our customers are trying to access
the app is that 9:00 p.m. at night and
so if we try if we leave that to
somebody else who are more of third
parties we it's a detriment to us and so
we want to to be able to partition that
problem as well and it and attack it to
improve the customer satisfaction and
improve the overall information we can
provide to our customers
thanks Dallas and Dallas will be coming
back up in a minute for the Q&A so
questions you've got about that process
he'll be back up here so let's take a
look at one last story before we have
our panelists come up and the learning
on this one is follow the ROI and what
we mean by this is during any
conversation around re-platforming
adding new technology moving something
to the cloud switching providers there's
gonna be a point at which you sit down
and determine what's it gonna cost us
first what's it gonna gain us and for a
lot of IOT products the first round of
their launch is highly experimental I've
been surprised that the amount of
customers that we've talked to have been
very honest in saying the first time we
launched something that was connected it
was just because our competitor launched
something that was connected or the
first time we launched it it was because
we thought it was a cool idea and we
wanted to see if we could figure it out
but over time if you get to the point
maturity with your product that you're
thinking about a reap LAT forming it's
because your companies found some value
from it now this is a statistic that
came out fairly recently which is that
1% of gathered data is properly analyzed
and made use of in IOT devices which
sounds shocking but when you consider
that you're launching devices connecting
to the Internet your first impulse is
let's wire up absolutely everything and
collect it into a data like and we'll
figure out what to do with it later it
becomes a bit clearer it's not the right
way to approach the problem the next
estimate is 75% of IOT initiatives are
failing and that one's even more
surprising but they both come from the
same place when this is discussing IOT
initiatives it's not talking about
products that are out there in the field
it's talking about that kind of thinking
around maybe we should connect it
because or maybe we should connect it
because our competitor has or maybe we
should collect a bunch of data and
figure out what to do with it in
retrospect and they set in these cycles
where nobody goes back for re-evaluation
and the learning from this one is if
you're at the point where you're
thinking about adding a new technology
you're probably also at the point where
you can tell where's my business model
in here and for a lot of companies it
comes from different ways it could be
that you've added a feature that allows
you to sell the product for more it
could be that you've added something
allows you to differentiate the product
in the market it could be that you've
converted what was previously a device
that people bought into a service that
people had and a recurring basis maybe
you figured out how to make a repair
service out of whatever your consumer
commercial product is or maybe you've
figured out how to make a third party
network of vendors and operators and
repair people and installers that you
can sell repair data to at the end of
the day a lot of the IOT products that
launch and get to the point of reap lat
forming know that in the back of their
heads and so the suggestion when you're
thinking about reap lat forming is
follow exactly that don't go for a
wholesale work on the technology that's
driving where your company's value is
coming from so these are some of the
classic use cases from the ROI of a
product that you might want to double
down on you can probably take a look at
your product and figure out which aspect
of this technology is the one that's
really driving our new feature or our
ability to deliver service and as a
product as a service with high uptime
and availability or is this allowing us
to run our product at lower cost to
ourselves so make sure that your
platform is themed around that so for a
final story before we bring up our
panelists I want to invite up Paul and
he's going to talk to us about a use
case that was exactly like this with a
product called Sky kit
hey everyone Paul Lundberg from Agosto
so we were talking to a customer one day
and they basically started to ask for
what they thought was an application and
what we quickly viewed as a product and
so we went out to try to help them find
the product because it didn't make sense
to build it for one customer and we
found that what they were asking for
just wasn't out there in the market and
so we couldn't help ourselves but to
start to investigate this and to go down
the path of starting to build out what
we thought could be a product so it's a
digital signage solution that is built
entirely on Google and uses Chrome OS as
the endpoint media player so there's a
lot a lot of people out there that love
Chrome OS for its security and
lower cost and and manageability and so
we started to go down that path we had a
lot of experience with Chrome OS we had
love experience developing on Google's
cloud and and there were only 600 other
companies with digital signage products
so we thought why not we'll jump in and
give it a go so based on Chrome OS we
started with a micro services
architecture I'll go into a little more
detail on that entirely built on Google
cloud platform and I'll get into this a
little more some of the learnings that
we really kind of already knew from
doing product development for other
companies is that in building a product
it's continual redevelopment I mean the
the technology changes the requirements
changes the scaling the scaling of the
product changes and so you're
continually just looking at how do we
and as everyone has talked about so far
that's been up here how do we
incrementally move this product forward
and you know we've got the plane in the
air and we have to do this live so let
me just show you roughly what our very
high-level architecture looks like so in
in the big blue box here we have a few
of the micro services that we built out
initially one was responsible for
managing content customers create
content format content and they want to
schedule that to plan players put it in
playlist set all kinds of rules and tags
about where that's going to play and
then sky could admin service is another
micro service that is all about
abstracting the device management and to
make make it really straightforward for
customers to manage their fleet of
devices behind the scenes were
interfacing with Chrome device
management interfacing with a logging
service and largely this architecture is
very much like a mobile architecture in
that we couldn't always count on our
devices being online so we had to think
about that in retail or many of the
places where these devices go
connectivity
is an issue in terms of Wi-Fi it's dry
it's going down it's coming back up we
need to be able be able to always play
the content when we have the opportunity
pull the content down be ready to play
whatever updated content there is it's
available so so we had a micro services
architecture devices on the edge we were
doing push notifications using Google
Cloud messaging very much a mobile
architecture platform and so then at
that time when we built this product
Google's cloud platform was a was very
different in terms of the services
available so as an example we didn't
have pub/sub available to us and IOT
core was not available yet to handle
MQTT messaging so when those started to
come around and as we were building our
own experience around IOT and other
projects we started to really think
about this product as being really an
IOT product in that we've got a lot of
devices out there that we're trying to
manage and so we started thinking about
how do we start to move this
architecture into more of an IOT pattern
and how do we leverage the services of
the writ that are available on Google's
cloud so this isn't a picture of the
entire architecture this is really
drilling down into more of a view of of
IOT
[Music]
so we have our sky cat player which is a
media player HDMI cable driving a panel
a big change is that everything we were
doing up until the new architecture was
HTTP and MQTT is a lower-level protocol
very good for IOT and that we can
maintain a connection as long as we're
as long as we have it and have traffic
flowing both ways it's a much lighter
protocol in terms of the overhead and it
also gives us with IOT core a much
better model for security in terms of us
securing each individual device and
really turning some of that
responsibility over to Google in terms
of their underlying IOT core offering
so our general philosophy in developing
products is use what's available as core
components on Google's cloud and build
what you have to and when Google comes
out with a service where they're taking
responsibility for the scaling and all
the complexities then then move to that
and you know don't support that code
anymore that you developed in a custom
way so so what's really important with
the new architecture is that now that
our products becoming more complex and
we're looking at adding to it instead of
just a couple micro services that are
communicating between one another we
have more micro services that are going
to be coming into the picture and what's
really great about IOT core and pub/sub
working in conjunction is that as
messages come into the system through
IOT core and get put on to pub/sub
queues we can have multiple subscribers
- - to that to that data so now if for
example we have let's say player state
what's going on with the player coming
in through pub/sub both the sky kit
admin which is responsible for devices
and the content manager where we want to
show in the UI to a user what the state
of a device is we can just have both of
them subscribe and show that we don't
have to have it come in through sky kid
admin and then make sure we communicate
that to two content manager so it's a
much more scalable solution it also
gives us the opportunity to as an
example let's take data and just move it
into bigquery let's have multiple
subscribers where we can just have
another subscriber to that data and
start to look and and think about how we
can how we can use that stream of data
in a different way so so our learnings
out of all this were you know just can
continual redevelopment have it have
that kind of mindset we're also trying
to position our product so that we have
a lot of flexibility so where's the ROI
we don't know exactly but we know that
we want to be as flexible as possible so
as an example we have had a customer
come to us in fact now our largest
customer that said well we really like
your sky kick product it's built on
chrome problem is we've got 10,000
devices deployed today that are running
on an Android device so what we did then
was to rebuild just that player
component if you remember the bigger
architecture picture the player is just
one component we we were able to
redevelop that in Android and connect it
and and and get that working so that we
could could win that deal so we don't
know exactly what the future holds but
we know we know that if we can architect
our system to be as flexible as possible
that another opportunity might be a
panel provider that says we have a
system on chip in our panel and if you
could develop it in a certain way then
we could run your product and we could
help you sell your product when we have
a big deal we could bring that to you so
so we know that by being as flexible as
possible and having an architecture that
supports us moving quickly and
supporting as many different
possibilities as we can that that were
likely to have success so Fraser I think
you're gonna open up the panel okay I
think we'll keep using this one - thanks
a lot Paul so I'm going to invite a
couple panelists up now one is Dallas
you've heard from and Paul representing
Scott KITT and as well we've got the
pleasure of welcoming Verena up from ATO
so these are three people who have gone
through replac farming's themselves and
their companies have taken a look at the
ups and downs and walk through it and
we'll get a chance to ask them some
practical questions from it
so I'll kick us off with a question for
each of you and then if you want to take
a moment to introduce yourself as we go
along as well I the first question that
I'm wondering is what was that moment
like because a lot of we platforming
products start with the worry that
you're wasting your time or you are
spending it inefficiently or something
could go wrong along the way what was
the moment that really tipped the scales
that told you no this investment is
worth what we're putting into it okay
good afternoon well we started with this
project about 12 years ago we decided to
create a kind of open platform that can
be used for the telematics of the group
so we started we started installing all
of this in about 4,000 buses when we
over the years we have been working with
this but at some point we were not able
to create to construct more things over
this platform so it became something
that was a black box that was not where
we cannot do something new when you guys
you came with us we discovered that
there we had an opportunity for changing
things and the first step that we did is
to try to create a small bullet tracer
as you said and with this bullet tracer
that we identified that there was no no
risk no real risk in following this
methodology and in in creating a better
you know an IOT platform an open
platform in the existing hardware so
right now we feel pretty confident that
it is the time to ask al this and we we
hope that in the following months we're
going to be able to set up all of this
platform in some more bosses so we we
are ready for that we feel more
confident I'm still working for the
company so
I'm not getting fired yet and I'm pretty
sure it's not going to happen because we
feel we are in very good hands and the
methodology is one that is telling you
when you go you can go to the next step
and to the other step so we feel very
confident on that yes I think it's just
it's been an evolution over the the five
years that has been around as I as I
said when I spoke earlier and that as we
focused on the beginning on launching
our pulse oximetry and that data that
we're trying to provide for our
customers once we kind of got our feet
underneath us on that we then started
seeing where else we could improve and
that's the next part of our product is
is really how the data gets to the
customer we can provide the data now we
have accurate data and so once we were
like confident of that that was that
product is there obviously will improve
that even of itself but we started
seeing we call it the forest we start
chopping down the big trees and then you
start seeing what else is growing up and
the biggest tree next was our platform
and so that's what we're doing is we're
taking one tree down at a time an I'd
answer that by saying that initially
when we're building the product were
we're not thinking about scale as much
we just want to see it work for a
customer to customers ten customers and
so we're focused a lot on the
application and is it functioning and is
it doing what the customer is wanting
and expecting it to do does it have the
right features can we compete and then
there the tipping point for for us is
really when you your primary worry is
about scale so you know the product is
working customers are reasonably
satisfied there's an endless
roadmap of features to build but the
thing that could really get us is if if
we can't scale and if we can't move
quickly to address concerns as we see
them in terms of in terms of scaling and
and with this type of solution it's
about it's about device management it's
about having the data to answer
questions it's about having having good
data about device State and things like
that so so when we really started to
think about re architecting it was it
was really around the product works it
looks like it's a go but how are we
gonna scale so I'll take a second if
there's a question from the audience
before another question for our
panelists there's a microphone just up
here for anyone so I'll I'll ask you a
question very night about a do you had a
decision to migrate your back office for
your operations to Google cloud and what
do you think was the the biggest impact
of moving your back office from where it
was before into a cloud-based operation
okay the first one was about costs
because our platform is based typically
you know the standard platform based on
local computers local servers and this
is very very expensive
any time you require some more
processing computing computing power or
some or data storage you need to buy
some more computers this is not anymore
the case with a cloud so in terms of
cost it is it has a huge huge impact the
other one is about ubiquity we have
operations in different cities around
the world and the thing here is that it
is absolutely wonderful not having to go
to Spain or other countries and
installing infrastructure since
everything is already in the cloud
you're able to go anywhere and the third
thing is about connectivity most of our
customers are not only the ones who are
traveling with us in this in the bosses
but also the cities and the series today
we all know that what they want is open
data so the connectivity provided by the
cloud is amazing and we don't have to do
anything by ourselves we don't need to
develop new technology we don't need to
develop anything for providing these
open data to the to the cities thanks so
for you Dallas on a specific point
you're in the middle of migrating your
user applications and you mentioned that
you've never really seen a difficult to
please group of users until you've seen
tired frustrated parents who just want
to make sure their baby is okay so this
is a really strategic but it's also
really sensitive project for you so as
you were going into it what were some of
the considerations that you had about
migrating user applications and mobile
applications on something that's already
out there in the field
so we're that that's a very good
question when it comes to how do you
handle stressful parents and so I think
that what we're doing is we're trying to
release it at the same time as new
features and so this time we launched
this we're actually launching a
brand-new product and we're also going
into the UK coming at the end of the
year and with that move we're gonna kind
of marry that with the improvements for
gdpr and so if we were to just to say
hey because it's a pain right now with
our platform and let's move over it's
kind of hard to sell the reason why you
have to set up your device again and
essentially this REE platforming
unfortunately causes the old system did
not work and then the new system to take
over so what we we don't want to upset
our parent or parents or customers too
much but we're also not going to force
them so on this move this reap lat
forming is a it's a slow migration we
will actually have our product in the
current apps still available for six
months and then we'll push our customers
towards it so they choose when they do
then we platforming so that word it's
not a critical time sometimes parents
aren't using the app until they get a
notification
that they that something's wrong and so
it would be the worst experience to get
a notification on your device and then
go to your app and it's like oh it
doesn't work sorry you needed to
download the new one so we don't want
that to happen and so it's two-sided we
marry it with new features new products
hey new things here now let's the three
platform and then also don't push them
and do a slow rollout great thanks and
Paul a question for you on on customers
as well you talked a bit about how the
technology changes you made allowed you
to roll out in new sites and with new
pieces of hardware what about on the the
customer side of things how do you sort
of draw the dotted line between
technical improvements and customer
happiness for a sky kit yeah so sky kits
a software is a service so our customers
really don't know or unnecessarily
understand the details about how we
deliver our product so for us it's just
about dependability so early on we we
had some issues with players being
offline for example with no connectivity
we're in our application it would say
well our last known state is that it was
but there was there were delays of war
state would be correct so it's really
about for our for making an architecture
that's going to make the product better
is one that is going to provide accurate
information about exactly what's going
on with the devices you know you know
fairly complex architecture sure thanks
so we have time for a question from the
audience we have one and if not I'll
wrap up with a question for each of our
panelists here and thank you game for
your time
okay if everyone's set here so a a
fishing question for our panelists here
you've all gone through or in the middle
of a reap lap forming process yourself
and some of the folks in the audience
are curious about exactly that which is
why they're this talk if you had to
offer a tip up to another company that
is thinking about the process right now
or knows it might come down the road
what would be something you'd say and
now that I'm on the other side I wish I
knew that what would be your tip for a
company thinking about a reap LAT form
Paulo hand off to you first sure
well I would say that at the theme I
think you've heard with all these
examples and all our stories are that
you want to figure out how to increment
only go after this I think it's it's
important to just identify you know
where what do we go after first and and
that can be there can be a lot of
different ways to look at that one I
think one of the examples was well let's
look for we're where we have a big
problem you know we're replacing that
part of the plot part of the application
could really help help us another might
be to just pick something straight
forward to get things underway a lot of
times you need to set this up and
convince people other than the technical
team that there's an investment to be
made and and you want to show some
success so so there's there's lots of
different reasons but those are those
are a few I'd offer what I would offer
is in any company you're trying to grow
your business so if you know it's coming
it's inevitable
don't wait start now and that's going to
take it by piece by piece but start now
because the more and more angry parents
that you have with the current situation
it just gets worse and worse and so you
want to start now please your customers
and do the best that you can we're gonna
do that with the UK instead of going in
and launching our old system on it we're
going to launch with a new system like
just we're staging it out because we
would get into the same boat we if we
launched UK with our old system we're
gonna have the same problems we're going
to have to reap lat form so launch now
so start now well I I guess that the
first thing is to ask the right question
what is the reason for replied forming
is this because you have technology that
is becoming older technology is going to
be
older anytime you know since the first
deployment you have after this it's
going to be older and over so I get the
right question here is how what is the
service what is the kind of service that
I want to propose to my customers in the
future knowing that the world is
changing very fast in our case the
question was what is the competitiveness
that I'm going to have with my customer
series in the future if I don't have an
IOT platform to offer for offering them
new new possibilities so in our case is
just because not because of technology
is because we are not going to have
something valuable to prove to propose
them in the very very near future so
that's why we are starting right now
it's a question of survival of the
business Oh Paul Dallas Bernie thank you
again for joining us and to everyone in
the audience thank you
[Music]